one of the things that I'm really
intrigued to learn more about is the tie
they're saying that being obese is like
a brutal factor in terms of mortality
rate with khoka 19 which is scary but I
don't understand the mechanism I don't
know if you know much about it well yeah
I paid close attention to Cove in
nineteen have seen articles about
obesity what's interesting is that in in
the studies that I've read that have
looked at the existence of pre-existing
conditions and their relationship with
both hospitalization and and death
obesity hasn't been quantified they've
looked yes they've looked at diabetes
and blood sugar issues they looked at
cardiovascular disease they've looked at
kid chronic kidney disease it looked at
smoking but they actually haven't
characterized obesity as one of those
risk factors now we know that many
people who are obese not everyone but
many people who have who are obese also
have either pre-diabetes or diabetes and
one of the theories right now this is
not proven there's a lot more research
that's needed is that one of the
pathological perhaps the main
pathological mechanism of kovat is that
it interferes with oxygen deliverability
with hemoglobins ability to deliver
oxygen to the cells and this is one
theory why ventilators are not working
as well as as they would hope and may
even be causing harm you know very high
percentage of people who are ventilated
end up dying and there aren't any
leaders for a much longer period of time
than would typically be expected is that
the ventilator can't necessarily move
the oxygen around that's the job of
hemoglobin and if there's something
that's causing hypoxia or lack of oxygen
then then malade ER in that situation
wouldn't necessary
what I heard and those lines tell me
this is what you've heard as well is
that basically the ventilator is working
in a mechanical level for somebody that
has a traditional pneumonia
you're just so fatigued you you almost
can't do the physical act of breathing
anymore and so the ventilator is going
to help you add it's it's going to force
your lungs to move and for you to
breathe but if the problem is at a
cellular level and you're just not able
to to shuttle the oxygen essentially do
the gas exchange right that it doesn't
matter whether you're exactly actually
breathing of that and the reason that
diabetes is problematic one reason and
then once in a speculative mechanism
here is that in in diabetes hemoglobin
becomes glycated with sugar
it becomes already exactly so the blood
sugar levels are high really fast and
not me interrupt you there I'm just
curious so are people that are
struggling with diabetes are they
already having a problem with oxygen
transport yeah I think that's fair to
say that that's especially when you see
the levels of anyone see get higher that
that's that's one of the issues with
diabetes so you know we can also extend
that to say that anything that
interferes with oxygen deliverability
including anemia which hasn't yet been
measured as contributing risk factor
pre-existing condition is important and
this of course takes us back to the
relevance of a nutrient-dense diet
because you know the most common cause
of anemia is iron deficiency anemia
which affects 2 billion people around
the world two billion people mostly in
developing in developing countries but
here in the US it's still a big issue
particularly among people who are
malnourished and are undernourished and
you know underserved communities and
then there are other causes of
nutritional nimi - like b12 and folate
deficiency a lot of drugs and this is
another double whammy effect here a lot
of people who have diabetes take
metformin and metformin depletes folate
and b12 levels which can cause or
contribute to a nutritional anemia b12
macrocytic anemia so I don't think we've
even begun to get a grasp on all of the
different ways that these mechanisms
commingle and interact with one another
so do they haven't quantified obesity
yet they obviously
you said looked at several different
things do you have a rough order of like
what are the most terrifying underlying
conditions I know smoking is brutal
because of the way that it compromises
the lungs is that the worst thing that
you could be doing is diabetes the worst
thing like what are the the most
troubling underlying factors have they
sort of ranked them different studies
have found different results diabetes
seems to be at the top of the list and
most of the studies that I've seen which
was actually surprising you know given
that this is a restless would be a
respiratory illness I think we would
have thought that people with you know
pre-existing lung conditions would rank
at higher risk for for complications but
if this is if this theory about hypoxia
salya at a cellular level is true and
diabetes impairs oxygen deliverability
then that makes sense right it's not
just so much about the lungs themselves
but about the whole body systemic
response to the illness but certainly
people with chronic lung disease and and
including asthma so some of the younger
people who have died from kovat have
been people with asthma that were
otherwise relatively healthy they didn't
necessarily have diabetes or
cardiovascular disease or anything else
they had and and they didn't even
necessarily have you know fully active
asthma like people who are
immunocompromised so that can include
people who've undergone you know
chemotherapy or cancer treatment
you know immune deficiencies prolonged
use of corticosteroid drugs like people
with autoimmune diseases who've been
taking prednisone or something like that
for a long time
chronic kidney disease which I mentioned
is another major risk factor and liver
disease even the CDC has said that
severe obesity with like people with a
BMI over 40 is a risk factor but I think
it's likely that just you know regular
obesity obesity with a BMI less than 40
could be a risk factor - especially if
it's showing up with diabetes or
prediabetes what do you think about
cardio so I despise for you I really
only do Part II when I'm really trying
to get lean but
legitimately about seven minutes ago I
thought the second this interview is
over I am going to a treadmill because
if this is around the ability to lung
capacity red blood cells getting grab
oxygen around Zachary I'm getting my my
cardio on point might be truly something
to really consider I agree a hundred
percent I'm with you I don't love cardio
I'll do it if it's in the context of
something that I enjoy doing like I like
to surf I like to ski I'm not doing it
obviously either of those right now I
like to ride my bike I think really
anything that improves your blood flow
right now so even strength training
although it's not necessarily an
increasing lung capacity it's probably
increasing blood flow which is a good
good thing to do right now of course
diet is critical always but it's even
more so now especially if you're someone
who's at risk for you know higher blood
sugar the reality at least from what I
am reading and seeing is is that this is
you know while the we might reach the
peak case the number of cases from this
initial wave in the next couple of weeks
Cove it's not going anywhere anytime
soon and you know I wish that we're not
true but it's it this is likely gonna be
with us in some capacity for you know 12
to 18 months and maybe even seasonally
for you know until there's an effective
vaccine developed so what this means is
that it's not just a question of like
what do you do tomorrow or in the next
couple of weeks to prepare it's what do
you do for the next year or two and
going forward to reduce your your risk
and one of the most important things for
sure is to control your blood sugar so
if you're someone who's got pre-diabetic
or diabetic level blood sugar then you
know taking action through diet to lower
that blood sugar considerably and get it
back into normal range I would think is
the probably one of the biggest ROI
things you could do so that could be a
low carb diet a keto diet you know
protein sparing modified fast there are
a number
Dietary Approaches that have been proven
to be effective for diabetes but it also
means strength training getting enough
sleep managing your stress all of these
things are also really important when it
comes to lowering blood sugar by just
stress alone which is hard to avoid
right now raises cortisol and what does
cortisol do what's its main job in the
body is to raise blood sugar when it
falls too low now that was an
evolutionary mechanism when we would go
periods of time without eating and our
blood sugar would drop cortisol would be
there to keep it stable but that
backfires on us now when if most
people's blood sugar doesn't ever fall
too low and cortisol is just raising it
to unhealthy levels so those are you
know I think sleep physical activity
exercise strength training cardio stress
management which is even more critical
now than ever before and a diet that
specifically a diet that manages blood
sugar levels are probably the most
important things people can be doing
right now if someone is feeling sick
right now and maybe they have
coronavirus maybe they just have the flu
or some type of cold or something else
maybe they're causing sickness because
of the mind and how they're stressing so
much who knows why sigh what would you
say people should do obviously if
they're if they're sick they should
probably stay quarantine with this
practice but what should they do in
terms of just feeling better to try to
strengthen the immune system and weaken
the sickness what is something they
could do every day is it 20 minutes a
day of breathing like you said an ice
and doing the ice stuff even if they
feel weak will that help
is it more breathing what's the strategy
to increase the immune system if they
feel weak then they should do the
breathing exercises the breathing
exercises changes the chemistry brings
down the inflammation and when it is
brought down through the breathing
techniques not aged
do a little bit of breathing yeah I
breathe already oh all day long no not
that way
just follow the protocol which these
guys in university also did also those
people are humans so you are human
follow the protocol and then it will
show you will bring down inflammation
which was weakening the person so the
person feels weak he brings down through
the breathing techniques the
inflammation many feel strong again
he feels connection again and that is
feeling strong from there starts to
fight off the the sickness yes the
inflammation goes down with that the
sickness and with that he feels
yes control within his immune system at
will again gives confidence and great
feeling that is one and then from there
then take a hot shower take a cold one
afterwards from 30 seconds to 2 minutes
and you're gonna feel even greater
because you are exercising and
activating the transportation system of
your body and it's all logic what is
breathing help boost the immune system
by itself wise air into your body in
your cells why does that help
yes when we do these breathing exercises
we have shown in the university they
work different than any other breathing
technique I have been looking up and
I've gone through signs to show it so
that it's factual its factual this
breathing techniques I've been
exercising randomly by going into cold
water and cold water is real stress and
when real stress comes and you are able
by certain kinds of ways
Oh bleep then those breathing techniques
that is able to fend off the stress of
the cold and so that those breathing
techniques
after being so much in the court I took
home I began to do those same breathing
techniques which I was doing before but
a to friend of the court I took the ball
and began to exercise at home and then
it shows Wow disposed people it changes
my consciousness it changes my eyes I
know that by going into a cold water and
cold water is merciless but righteous is
what I always say but it is so it is my
teacher if it works in cold water it
will work against any virus and or any
bacteria love that and and and more so
you know if you learn how to deal with
cold water which is very stressful which
goes directly into your emotion you
learn also to deal with your emotion
with your mood and this has now been
shown in the in the brain scans that I'm
able to connect with the areas where
emotion is a residing where while stress
is coming upon my body I was able to
feel euphoria and you could not miss
because you could see the brain and
within the brain you know where is the
area of emotion and where's the area of
between and and and sensation and they
saw it all and that was for the first
time all learned in the cold water then
I took that breathing dose of those
became techniques I took them home began
to do them all and it's amazing
I also and then I went to the University
and they gave me an injection I began to
do these breathing techniques and the
bacteria at no chairs if you want more
advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there I knew we
were going to have a tsunami but I
didn't know it was gonna be Corona